[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good ready for what's coming
[Music]
Jackson storm is part of the next
generation of high tech racer rookie
sensation Jackson Stone Jackson storm
storm in a class of his own hey champ
got a good run you have no idea what a
pleasure it is for me to finally beat
you did you say meet or beat I think you
heard me enjoy your retirement
you'll never be the racer you once were
you can't turn back the clock kid but
you can wind it up again the racing
world is changing treadmills Winton's
virtual reality still working on that
and interactive race simulation I've
jumped a barrier you have crashed we got
some work to do I am so excited that I
get to train you visualize beating
the beach ate me every week veteran
racers retire to make room for these
younger faster research okay your
questions paparazzi you'll never be as
fast to storm but you can be smarter
good luck out there you're gonna need it
I decide when I'm done
you are not winning this
coming for you storm
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
down
2% time
ready for what's coming
more of everything
we'll never be the racer you once were
you can't turn back the clock
you can wind it up again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you are about to become the biggest
brand in racing movie deals infomercial
product endorsements good chow you think
you're famous now will be rich beyond
belief mr. Serling what is this about
your legacy every time you lose you
damage yourself I'm sorry your racing
days are coming to an end
we can only hope that this race today
wasn't his last I decide when I'm done
how you feeling I can't go out on the
track and do the same old thing it won't
work it's futile there is this changed
man you know what I do what I don't know
I got nothing I am so excited to train
you I like a challenge
haha I call you my senior project run
your mouth got a sad huh
the beach ate me Jackson storm set a new
record today when he pulled off the
fastest lap at ever recorded
how you feeling the latest record storms
beside me even any doctor eaten a queen
this is my last chance Cruz last if I
lose I never get to do this again
don't fear failure be afraid of not
having the chance you have the chance I
used to watch you on TV flying through
the air you seemed so fearless it was
shiny wood that felt like
[Music]
you'll never be as fast to store but you
can be smarter than him
Racing is the reward not to stop candy
are 95%
[Music]
[Music]
you will never be the racer you once
were except it will Michel McQueen
retired I decide when I'm done
Jackson's storm is part of the next
generation of high-tech racers we're
number three for the rookie sensation
you'll never be as fast but you can be
smarter you need my help mr. McQueen
I'm coming for you storm
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you'll never be the racer you once were
you can't turn back the clock kid
[Applause]
we are so excited to watch the road to
the races tour here at Disney springs in
Walt Disney World this tour has
something for absolutely everyone I need
to hear the excitement excitement this
is where it can take a photo with our
characters cruise she's our new leading
lady in this film she's a fierce
technician that's going to get Lightning
McQueen prepared to go into competition
he's gonna be facing off against
Jackson's storm he's a next-gen racer
this guy is built to be unbeatable
he's very confident rookie sensation if
you're feeling competitive today you can
get off to the races
we have Lightning McQueen and Cruz
Ramirez diecast models that you can race
down a ramp on the other side of this
experience you can play with the latest
and greatest toys fed from the towels
and cars 300c crest oral-b is the
perfect place to spin the wheel win a
prize and get a photo at the star of car
streets Lightning McQueen
make sure you have your taste buds ready
to try something that's really fantastic
at Dole we're so excited for guests to
be able to try amazingly themed smoothie
this one is inspired by Lightning
McQueen you can also learn about the
recipe behind them as well at Alamo we
have a mural wall that everyone can come
out color and bring to life a photo of
all the characters of cars we have some
artists up here we've partnered with
NASCAR acceleration nation this is
really going to educate folks on the
math and science behind NASCAR a really
cool activity that you can do today is
create a 3d model of some of the stars
of the film and then if you're really
feeling super creative you can create
your very own car right here
make sure you stop by the Coppertone
booth we have a variety of sunscreen for
everyone to try our new Coppertone
whipped this is my personal favorite
right now the pit crew challenge all
right come on you guys baby back on the
road whatever has left lug nuts on there
at the end of 30 seconds it's dead away
Wow I don't know if you guys have ever
seen something like this before this is
absolutely amazing all right head on in
cinah transformer mobile movie theater
is going to show gas 13 minutes of
footage from the film this is footage
that no one has ever seen before an
exclusive to the road to the racing
school
we're so excited to have the road to the
races who are travelling to 27 cities
this summer next up we have Miami and
we're going to other cities like
Philadelphia New York Chicago San Diego
and Denver just to name a few head on
over to car Street or calm to check out
the locations and dates in your area and
make sure to check out the film when it
hit theaters June 16th see you there
[Music]
you